what's with Gavin Newsom
well you know I was born and raised in
Florida I never saw a California license
plate my whole life in Florida and why
would you I now I know people are going
to write to me and say David what is
wrong with Ron DeSantis why why does his
head shake like that I am going to
remind everybody to our knowledge Ron
DeSantis does not have a condition that
would cause any kind of shaking or
Tremors uh nothing parkinsonian he
doesn't have tardive dyskinesia or any
of that if he did we would not be
pointing this out this is a move that
Rhonda Santos does to seem engaging and
laid back he just his his head moves
like a bobble head and he could float on
out of the screen if you're not careful
it's a very weird trait and he needs he
needs some kind of a personality
transplant Trump was right